et juste avant je vais vous montrer un
petit truc qui a dont on a beaucoup
parlé
c'est l'histoire de luc ferry vous avez
vu ou paris luc ferry l'ancien ministre
de l'éducation luc ferry qui est invité
sur non-stop people le philosophe est
revenu sur son train de vie sa situation
financière et expliquant qu'il n'avait
pas de retraite de mini c'est qu'il
n'arrivait pas à vivre avec 3000 euros
par an par mois des armoires encore
regardez regardez cette secte non
seulement on n'a pas de retraite de miss
mais quand on est ministre on cotise soi
même voilà donc j'ai zéro j'ai juste
mais vous êtes combien comme en algérie
retraite massa va très bien mais j'ai ma
retraite de professeur d'université qui
nous est de 3000 euros donc 3000 euros
pour votre là et puis et puis par
ailleurs j'ai tout mais j'ai mes droits
d'auteur c'est toujours avoir aussi une
retraite du que du conseiller économique
et social parce que je vous dis ne veut
pas dire de bêtises qui doit être de 800
vous aussi vous faut qu'on a envie de
revivre luc ferry bas il faut beaucoup
plus que ça parce que j'ai j'ai des
filles qui sont encore jeune j'ai déjà
aidé j'ai deux filles qu'on 20 et 21 ans
et 3000 euros de retraite vous n'arrivez
pas à vivre ah ben non je vais
évidemment pas alors derrière donda à
polémiquer et a su de cette polémique il
a tenu à réagir sur les réseaux sociaux
expliquant qu'ils ne se plaignait
absolument pas de sa situation regardez
j'ai fait une émission de télé l'autre
jour un journaliste m'a demandé quel
était le revenu j'ai répondu honnêtement
parce que j'aime pas me défiler que
j'avais ma retraite de profs qui en vaut
trois mille euros plus les droits
d'auteur je ne me plains nullement mais
il faut arrêter de m'emmerder avec ça je
suis locataire je suis pas propriétaire
j'ai mes droits d'auteur gema retrait de
profs riendeau je suis pas un arabe
je ne me place au lui ment pas mais
foutez moi la paix j'ai le droit d'avoir
ma retraite et les droits d'auteur il
faut quand même sortir de ce monde
on vous pour vous faire des procès alors
que j'ai juste une retraite de profs et
les droits d'auteur mes livres je veux
dire la vérité
moi je suis d'accord avec fériés sont
tous tombés dessus ouais ça va le mec il
n'est pas langue de bois oui il ya tous
les mois comme jules verdez là qui nous
choque c'est parce qu'il ya prison le
remède c'est sûr cislo c'est une très
belle somme à la met en relief au moins
il est la vérité la vérité et de la
vérité ou nous tombe dessus il habite à
paris on a fini à des études m'a forcé
par des versions c'est très beau courir
près de 3000 euros il a très peu qui l'a
bien sûr elle moins mille îles le lieu
derrière qu'il ait privilégié une
oreille mais honnête là où il ya plein
de gens qui mentent quand on leur posera
bien sûr clairement qu'ils viennent plus
que 3000 euros par mois puis avec sa
retraite mais tant mieux pour lui il a
pas et en plus il se fait défoncer
derrière parce qu'il est on est bien
chaud en été ou non franchement je
il est pas venu fanfaronner on lui pose
la question il répond donc défilé très
honnêtement je ne jouerai pas la parole
sur ce sujet non parce qu'il ya plein de
gens qui veulent pas vous entendre on
vous a beaucoup vous abel chéri ah ben
moi je suis entièrement d'accord avec
guillou je trouve ça scandaleux quand
ils répondent pas et bien selon le bois
quand il répond dans leur tombe dessus
en disant vous êtes un privilégié
effectivement quand on fait le décompte
par rapport à bien d'autres dans sa
situation de l'ancien ministre il est
absolument pas pris le regard dans
l'avis des téléspectateurs en direct la
à 19h10 ou au civil et le pcot alors oui
je suis d'accord parce qu'en fait il a
une de ses filles qui est à l'école
hôtelière de lausanne vd dont 120 cher
c'est de savoir il n'a aussi je bosse
ici
sa place et ses filles c'est avec la
marque en emmerde avec ça cela dit donne
des conférences aussi il donne de
grandes conférences bon ça il en a pas
parlé parce que c'est un très brillant
philosophe un lion des conférences assez
régulièrement
il fait payer en général 10 euros la
place pour l'entendre et c'est mérité
parce que c'est au moyen orient